so let's talk about peptides now
um to heal the body there's another link
that i got here so i'm just going to
throw it up so we can go through
them kind of like one by one sure um
let's see here remove at the stream
there we go
so this is from limitless nootropics
which is another company i'll grab the
link here for that one if you guys want
to get those peptides
again this is also pinned in the top
comments uh if you're watching the
replay
because the live chat from what i
understand doesn't always show up there
but um so let's go through them one by
one because the one that i've used is
bpc157 so let's start with that one
um i've used this for the last couple
years i first learned about it about
three or four years ago i was in a group
with actu with ben greenfield actually
just telling us to use this to
heal my knee because i've because i've
always had a bad left knee um
i've just done stupid things in my body
but whatever um
and it was a injectable so you'd have to
use
something like this to jam it in your
body and at the time i wasn't on trt i
wasn't familiar with
needles it wasn't something that i was
super excited about doing especially
jamming a needle into a knee joint
but you know after you get comfortable
with it when you get on trt it's like no
big deal and you
hurt your you know you hurt your knee
again or shoulder joint or something
like that
it's actually pretty easy to do um let
me just quickly go
full screen here to kind of educate you
guys a little bit because
this sort of stuff looks scary right
normally you know
you're going to use that to draw and if
you take a look at that
like i don't know if you can see the
needle but it's not small like you don't
want to go jamming that into your knee
joint
because it's not something that you're
uh
used to doing and it's obviously like
like your lizard brain is basically
saying what are you doing stupid
but if you draw the peptide into one of
these larger syringes
and then you backfill a insulin
syringe you know from the back over here
it does two things one it preserves the
integrity of the tip of your insulin
needle and it's also a much much smaller
needle this is a 30 gauge
5 8 all you have to do is basically
pinch your skin up
and just kind of you know put it in
between your fingers you know where you
pinch the skin
in that joint and then you inject a
little bit of peptide in there and this
stuff is like
it's like magic i can't even um you know
praise this
enough let me add this back to stream
there you are so talk about bpc157
how it works why it works um all that
stuff
so it is so first off let me echo your
sentiment it is magic
there is nothing that bpc157 which
stands for body protective compound
uh 157 so it's a peptide uh again a
bunch of a protein
amino acid protein sequence that causes
healing
um and again same thing is similar to
what ghk cu does
it increases the flow of red blood cells
stimulating collagen synthesis again
through the process of what is called
angiogenesis
all of this really what these peptides
are doing is massively
uh accelerating and stimulating your
body's natural
processes to repair and rebuild damaged
uh traumatized tissue so uh i've been
using by the way just so you know i've
been using bpc157 since 2011
um and then ipamrel which we'll talk
about since 2009 actually 2008.
so i've been using peptides for a long
time at one time you know peptides were
really just kind of an underground
you know bodybuilding fitness
enthusiasts performance enhancement
communities but now they're obviously
mainstream which we'll talk about but
bpc157
every man over the age of 35 should have
these in the refrigerator
year-round because if you get hurt
yeah anything you want to inject this
locally
to the point of origin in the tissue and
the healing response is
it's insane i mean i mean again like i
have this debate all the time with
orthopedic surgeons many of whom i'm
very good friends with
i won't mention some of their names but
they're like on one side of their world
they have
a regenerative you know functional
medicine practice where they're
prescribing peptides all their patients
are on the other side of the world
they're performing surgeries and acls
and mcl repairs and all that and grafts
and they're like
i always say to them i'm like how the
hell do you do that and they're like
well
it's really hard because you know i'm a
partner in this practice
so again medicine is now kind of in the
golden age dividing line where it's like
they have to decide whether they want to
write scripts for
peptides which they're obviously
precluded from doing unfortunately which
big pharma is making that happen versus
performing surgeries but richard just
real quick to summarize that
uh the smartest orthopedic surgeon that
i know in the world who's one of the top
three in the entire world
said and it's a she she said if i had my
druthers i would prescribe
tb 500 and bpc157 for every single one
of my male patients
over the age of 40 who came in wanting
an acl repair
or wanting an mcl repair because the
regrowth of those peptides
is far greater and creates more
stability
and surgery they
repair or reattach the tendons so it's
interesting to hear that from somebody
of that magnitude saying that so we both
know that
where these are going who knows yeah
um and when i injured my i.t
versus knee so what i did was i just
basically grabbed a
chunk of skin and fat like in the side
by my hip like where most of the pain
was
sure and i did a shot daily for about
four or five days
helped on yeah very easy to do
uh luckily i had a uh a bottle in my
fridge still
for my last order was my last bottle so
i gotta reorder so i gotta hop on here
and get some more for you guys but
yeah um yeah like this is something that
you like if you're involved in sports
uh you lift weights you run you play
soccer
like anything you know you're at a dojo
or anything if you get an injury you
don't want to sit around for
months trying to heal or just you know
moping about it on your couch
you know like a nancy get get this stuff
and keep it in your fridge
uh because it keeps for like how long
does this stuff keep
i mean truthfully you know that's a
great question like if it's in powder
form how long is it keeping your fridge
so life eliza can probably last for
years as long as you keep it
refrigerated but
even when you reconstitute it nick and i
have done this and we're gonna do a
podcast
or not a podcast but a blog about this
nick doesn't think that it will denature
below 72 so what that means is if you
keep it in your refrigerator even
reconstituted
again cool you're gonna get some value
out of it for a long time
okay but in powder form it you know it
can stay oh yeah no it'll maintain its
efficacy for probably
15 months in powder form yeah and it's
super like
do you guys sell the um water that you
have to use to reconstitute it or
so you can you know you can't get it um
from limitless they will sell it but i
mean he recommends and i recommend too
just to go on amazon or any place and
just buy bacterial static water in bulk
and put it yeah that's what i did
i just got a big tray of it and i just
buy it in bulk exactly um
okay so that's bpc157 that
that to me is by far the most useful
healing peptide that i've ever used
um let's just talk about biomass and
beta real quick because you want to use
both of them in combination so if you
seriously to
battle hang on a second let me just pull
it up here melatonin
so it's basically tb 500 is what people
know it and there's also pb400
uh but basically it's thymus and beta so
basically if you use combination
and you know this comes from nick but if
you use thymus and beta
and bpc157 in combination you will
literally accelerate healing seven to
10x and if you use them in like a very
you know industrial size
dosage you can literally repair torn
completely
torn tissue in like four weeks which
500 is more for the muscle and bpc157
targets a joint right
exactly exactly and you would inject tb
500 into the muscle or
yeah so you would you would i mean
basically that's a great question you
can actually do both
you can take one and syringe one you
know micro syringe uh
um and take the tb 500 and the ppc
together
and you know tail were made which
obviously you know poor tail were made
they're not being able to sell this
before but
anymore but they used to be able to put
them together i mean i still have
probably like five vials of tailor-made
stuff in my refrigerator what's a combo
of them
and whenever i get hurt i
instantly eject before i go to bed at
night but yeah i mean both of those
things will radically
um improve healing and speed healing and
they really are golden age medications
the idea that more people don't know
about them just blows my mind i got a
question here from a channel member on
youtube he says i'd love to know what
jay's opinion is on tb 500 protocol is
using tb 500 on a regular basis after a
loading phase so it's a great question
you and i should do a podcast
probably um on q a on peptides because
there's so much misinformation out there
it's important to know that no peptide
should be used all the time regularly
they should literally be used how would
i say it like you should there should be
like a dosage
um an autonomous kind of
get traumatized a serious critical acute
injury
then you should be using it probably you
know depending on when you heal but be
somewhere between
seven to twelve weeks eight to twelve
weeks maybe even six to eight weeks if
it's a
small injury but as far as protocols um
there's a lot of different ones
um i can actually i'll send it to you um
i'll share
nick's like acute versus non-acute
traumas and then you can just post them
in the notes without going into like a
detailed discussion but just remember
everything with peptides should be
cycled you should not be using well
actually with the exception of one
peptide which we'll talk about for
immunity
uh especially in the covidera um but um
but you should always cycle your
peptides
all right i want to hit on another one
that i've used um epitalon
so epitalon where did that one go
i just clicked it it took me to the
wrong page let's go back here
just so this one here there right so
epitalon explain what that is because
i've used that twice and
it's kind of funny because um i was
using it last um
winter and i think i did um i don't know
i did a cycle whatever it was that nick
had recommended
and around the time after that somebody
said in the comments dude stop dyeing
your beard but i wasn't dying my beard
it's like this stuff actually darkens
your hair like it like it stops the gray
from coming out so
explain what epitalon is so by the way
just so you know too that's funny i
mentioned that so this is oxana grow has
actually darkened my hair too
because you can kind of see like how
much gray is on the side
you see so it does the same thing but
basically
epitalon works in a very similar fashion
so basically what epitalon does is uh it
increases
telomere length okay so you want to use
um epitome like twice a year some guys
use it three times a year i would just
tell you to do it once every six months
but it's a very very powerful uh
life extension slash anti-aging uh
peptide because
we die and degrade as physical beings
through
the telomere um
it's basically an enzyme called
telomerase it the caps
shorten and fall off and the faster they
shorten and fall off the faster we age
and and what epitalon does is actually
extra
increases the length of the telomere so
essentially it enhances
and basically gives you longer life
so obviously what you noticed uh in the
darkening of your hair
telomeres are part of your dna uh
spiral spiral and obviously the
healthier your dna is the longer you're
gonna live
you know realistically speaking there's
a couple of people that have like tested
this stuff
and they've and they've had their
telomere length tested before using this
and after
and it's and it's proven to work yeah
yeah there's tons of science on uh
epitome that was like ryan smith
who's like the big um biochemist guru
from taylormade he loves epitome he
always talks about all the studies and
the
science and data on it um but that's
what you notice is you notice again
darkening again which is what peptides
are doing right same thing with the ghk
cu is it's it's strengthening the body's
biologic processes
of healing and rejuvenation and
restoration again through the process of
angiogenesis so that's what telomerase
is doing or i mean
epitome is doing is it's strengthening
your telomeres which is increasing all
the other biological processes of aging
so
it's not obviously a peptide that you're
going to use like you were used like
ipamaran or tessa morellin
or the healing peptides which we're
going to talk more about in a second
here but it is definitely something to
put into an anti-aging process i would
say if you're 45
and older should absolutely use epitalon
twice a year
yeah i've been i've been using it for
the last
i'm going to say a year and a half i'll
probably do another one come in november
december i usually grab one
uh towards the end of the year around my
birthday but uh yeah like i would
it's not cheap i mean for you to do like
a full cycle i think the last one cost
me about 700 bucks
yeah because you have to have enough
files and then the injection frequency
all of that by the way is that on the
site somewhere like where it tells
people how to use it and what frequency
yeah so i mean when you order um well
it's a great question you when you order
um they send you a pro package insert
with your products on like how to use
them and stuff like that but also their
customer service is amazing so if you
have a question
you know you just ping them and that and
actually that brings up a really good
point
a lot of guys watch our stuff and
they're like you know if jay and richard
are doing it then i want to do it too
you know i i tell guys all the time and
i'm actually a
part of the bottleneck here is that you
need to really educate yourself on
peptides because it's not something that
you can just like buy out of the package
and start using there's reconstitution
there's understanding microgram versus
milligram
nick and i have actually written a book
it's called the peptide
handbook it's absolutely amazing it
should have come out two months ago
you know no excuses but covet all the
other [ __ ]
the problem that we're having is
actually getting it into a
printable format with all the charts and
all the conversions and all that stuff
i've talked to four different
publications
i mean publishing companies and nobody
has anybody that is science geeky enough
to do what we need so that book nick and
i are gonna streamline it and we're
talking about it this weekend but that
book should be out first quarter early
first quarter of next year
and that book will be an absolute must
have especially for newbies and guys
that like want to learn how to use
peptides because again it's like little
things
about you know again reconstitution
what's the difference in a syringe
between milligrams and micrograms
you know how do i convert you know with
a peptide calculator so again it's
there's math and you know again little
idiosyncrasies that guys don't
understand i've never used peptides and
i get always and you probably will too
i get emails from guys saying dude i
don't understand or you know a guy
injects an entire bottle of tessa morel
instead of a microgram so again it's
there is some you know confusion around
peptides again because of the science
behind and by the way doctors are just
as clueless as the average joe
you